pop
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
voilà
[Musique]
et
oh
[Applaudissements]
non
o o
[Musique]
oh
e
on va faire la rocherie faut rentrer
maintenant il est trop tard et bien moi
la prochaine fois c'est moi qui habite
rohrer car tu es un peu trop tendance à
juger bonne tout et parle de margerie
c'est pourquoi me favorisera-t-il tulle
demandant aux ménages doivent arriver je
dois me changer ne vous attardez pas
pour aller à tout à l'heure
[Applaudissements]
allons-nous changer une aussi ça me
kramer arrive frigo à notre avantage
puisqu'il va donc de si extraordinaire
ce type là d'après la rumeur on dit
qu'il a du charme de la distinction du
mystère on dit que les femmes apprécient
beaucoup
on dit aussi qu'il est plein de fric
mais personne ne sait vraiment quoi il
est sa fortune personnelle
les aventuriers ont toujours exercé une
étrange fascination sur les femmes
et si le petit sucre et aux mamans tête
arthur
arthur arthur mon chéri ya 20 ans maman
viens et c'est humiliant allez viens
voir là haut comme ton coeur bat mon
chéri mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce
dingue
vous ne savez donc pas qu'on ne prend
jamais assez de précautions avec les
chiens les enfants on les tient en
laisse
vous êtes inconscients quoi rouler en
ville à cette allure qu'est ce que vous
cherchez à faire à bourg et les hôpitaux
je vous signale que c'est moi qui ai
failli me retrouver à l'hôpital à kout
de cette adorable petite bête
heureusement qu arthur était là parce
que tout de suite après le virage c'est
le port et vous faisiez de nounous alors
merci arthur et toutes mes excuses
retirez votre voiture de là ça fait
désordre
ah ça sinon je suis sûr qu'elle adore
les bébés phoques mais avec les hommes
un peu brusque monsieur kramer comme je
suis heureux que vous ayez pu venir
jusqu'au dernier moment nous avons
craint que vous ne vous des commandites
pire qu'un manque de tact suite était un
impardonnable manque de l'ue qui me
faisait une telle joie de ce week-end
bertini et mes amis sont très impatiente
de koné mais moi de même incroyable bien
fini si vous le permettez j'aimerais
prendre une douche ses longues
randonnées en leur charme mais je me
sens terriblement poussiéreux diego
prenez les bagages de monsieur
[Musique]
ça m'a paru une éternité je suis
certaine que tu te souviens à peine mais
moins voyant ça n'a tout de même pas
dans cette maison il faut conserver les
convenances me souviens que de trois
géants merveille et puis un beau matin
ça mais partir voulez mais dieu merci
maintenant tout va bien avec bertini tu
ne manque de rien dans le commerce des
armes
il n'y a pas de morte saison aussi
vaut-il mieux éviter toute familiarité
qui risquerait de lui déplaire
[Musique]
on
c'est un tyran un redoutable despote je
n'ai rien absolument rien à moi je me
considère comme sa propriété
je ne suis rien d'autre qu'un élément
décoratif un ornement qui flatte sa
vanité
on n'avait pourtant rien d'une pauvre
petite créature sans défense voulait pas
si fragile si quelqu'un doit d'abord et
l'autre je suis sûr que c'est bertini
qui sera à croquer tu m'as su rester
[Musique]
c'est ce qui fait votre charme
vous me suivez salée oui oui ça va bon
et continue qui vous seront livrés comme
d'habitude en containers par bateau
pistolet mitrailleur mitrailleuses
lourdes
c'est pour savoir si ça s'écrit avec et
où s
les deux ah bon et débarquer encore et
es9 aucune importance nous chaut meister
a appris le français avec un légionnaire
hongrois et il est suisse allemand je
croyais qu'il était neutre les suisses
pas dans le commerce
allez assez de commentaires enchaînons
débarquer à la fin du mois dans le port
de jakarta
ce foutu pas impossible voulez vous
regardez là haut dans le dictionnaire
jakarta aucun des dés comme dynamite
[Musique]
oh
reculait alors ça suffit
satisfait vous avez bien vu merci
frederico je te présente sa mme kramer
comme tu n'en finissait pas dicter sa
correspondance soyez le bienvenu
monsieur kramer très heureux de vous
connaître plaisir partagé monsieur
virginie j'espère que tu n'en a plus
pour longtemps
tout le monde attend pardonnez moi j'ai
quelques ordres à donner à saly caron ma
secrétaire monsieur sam kramer nous nous
sommes déjà rencontrés tout à l'heure en
ville oui il a failli écraser arthur le
hasard est grand et il fait parfois bien
les choses
c'est un point de vue monsieur cratère
grammer salies vous avez sûrement déjà
entendu parler de ça mme kramer qu'est
ce qu'il fait monsieur kramer est un
homme riche une personnalité un grand
voyageur vous ne lisez jamais les
journaux non les sports la politique
rien de tout ça ne m'intéresse et qu'est
ce qui vous intéresse à par arthur
évidemment excusez moi mais je dois
chercher le monde du port de jakarta
d'un dictionnaire dont je peux dire
c'est ça oui c'est ça merci mon cher
vous pouvez répéter dont nous hommes
politiques et ça s'écrit comme ça se
prononce
vous ne trouvez pas que c'est un petit
peu usées non excusez là mais parfois la
tendance à l'agressivité
oui oui j'ai déjà remarqué une enfant
qui a du caractère
vous pouvez m'écrire merci soyez gentil
de l'étape et le courrier ma petite
salle i bien monsieur
au fait c'est pas vous qui avait
descendu les chutes du niagara dans un
tonneau non mais si j'étais vraiment sûr
que cela puisse vous faire plaisir vous
savez il en faut plus pour
m'impressionner
elle est charmante
j'ai été abandonné par mon ancien
secrétaire au cours d'un voyage
c'est une intérimaire que j'ai ramené de
paris une ancienne danseuse déballer
kisting je crois qu'elle a eu des mots
avec le chorégraphe a savouré tenez vous
prenez un verre volontiers aux dans mon
coffre fort j'ai une petite merveille et
j'aimerais bien avoir l'avis d'un
connaisseur tels que vous
[Musique]
on va bien je ne crois pas que ce soit
une bonne idée de l'avoir invité
pourquoi devions faire en sorte que
bertini ne s'aperçoive que les choses
que le plus tard possible lorsque nous
serions loin une anicroche peut toujours
arriver on ne prend jamais assez de
précautions
tu as invité beaucoup de monde cette
soirée beaucoup pour qu'il y ait une
certaine animation
j'ai invité aussi le commissaire de
police mais tu es folle non au contraire
si tout se passe bien aucune importance
si j'ai pas le cas avec la réputation de
sam kramer et les innocents passe temps
qu'on lui prête c'est lui qui sera le
suspect
[Musique]
une belle pièce ça doit valoir une
petite fortune
un million de dollars mon cher je ne
suis pas aussi connaisseur que vous
l'imaginez
je me suis fait rouler je ne sais
combien de fois par les diamantaires moi
vraiment un fruit le legend se bâtissent
homme sait trop comment
même moi je suis un homme simple qui
aime la bonne chère les bons vins les
jolies femmes
il n'en faut pas plus pour que circulent
les ragots les plus ahurissants mais
vous ne les dément tepa
[Musique]
il
courrier monsieur
[Musique]
bravo maintenant salées
vous n'avez plus qu'à tout retaper sa
sûrement pas elle a fait exprès pas d'
excuses ne discutait pas aller dans la
tête mais je n'ai encore pour une heure
bien des lois je vais le faire en vous
laissez moi tranquille c'est pas le
moment
j'adore tapé à la machine et puis je
vais voir si je n'ai rien perdu de ma
rapidité
permettez moi si ça vous amuse
[Musique]
non alors venez vous installer sur la
terrasse pour que vous profitiez un peu
du soleil
je vais porter la machine non non j'en
prix
[Musique]
or
pourquoi fédou et ça c'est gentil dont
vous avez été démontré encore vos
cuisses à ce vieux port ça me prend
souvent jusqu'à présent il n'a pas
demandé
il m'a fait monter sur une échelle et il
était en dessous oui ce que je veux dire
oui parfaitement je préférais démontré
une bonne voie et qu'on en finisse
vous étiez dans ce bar était oui mais
vous savez les maîtres de ballet c'est
la dictature
alors quand on a un peu de personnalité
oui et ça vous en avait à revendre ce
téléphone merci vous n'allez tout de
même pas l'intention de continuer à
travailler avec ce boucher ce marchand
de canons se fait dans l'intérim on
pense qu'on trouve moi j'ai pas de
fortune personnelle je dis pas ça pour
vous vexer voilà bon alors là vous
faites très attention à la marche de
interligne qu'il est très très manière
qu là-dessus et puis là vous laisser une
grande place au dessus de son nom il a
une signature énorme et tarabiscoté
voilà bon jeu ménager un peu bon courage
merci ne les excite et pas trop hein
si quelqu'un m'ennuie je les appelle
[Musique]
j'avais juin
m
[Musique]
stade
voilà
[Musique]
tiens la jeune fille de la maison oui tu
veux passer tout le monde je cherchais
je cherchais mes boutons de manchette
les patrons étaient très contentes de
notre travail et ça donne droit à quoi
monsieur kramer a déjà pensé
[Musique]
sanaa vous êtes éblouissante une arène
portant les joyaux de la couronne
vous devez excité bien des convoitises
rien à craindre je suis bien gardé et
sous surveillance n'est ce pas frédéric
cros sa nature venir je voudrais te
présentes et luigi excusez moi
mais là
vous êtes un homme comblé mais retire
une femme ravissant un super de bijoux
de quoi provoquer en effet bien des
convoitises
c'est pourquoi celui ci est faux
faux
c'est une copie de celui que je vous ai
montré dans ma bibliothèque tout à
l'heure il parfaite imitation n'est ce
pas en effet c'est à s'y tromper le vrai
ne sort jamais de mon coffre fort il
faudrait posséder la combinaison ou
avoir un doigté exceptionnel
mais vous ne soupçonnez tout de même pas
rossana canton à monsieur kramer le goût
des très jeunes femmes peut toujours
s'attendre à ce qu'un jour ou l'autre
elles filent en emportant l'argentine
[Musique]
donc pas qu'elle en fait un peu trop
elle a du tempérament cette fille là
[Musique]
pourquoi
ah mais c'est
c'est vraiment dommage qu'elle ne soit
pas aussi doué pour taper à la machine à
écrire
aurait-elle d'aussi jolies jambes vous
venez danser non non non merci mes
rhumatismes
moi aussi je peux en faire autant vous
savez
[Musique]
oh
amis si le coeur vous en dit elle ne
demande que ça
elle le demande n'avait qu'un peu trop
d'assistance
[Musique]
le plus
le commissaire soir de commissaire si ni
monsieur sam karmann enchanté les
commissaires j'ai beaucoup entendu
parler de vous monsieur kramer par
certains de mes collègues
oui je donne beaucoup pour les oeuvres
de la police frédéric hohl et sont les
bafana volontiers simple vous prendrez
bien quelque chose comme il sait à vous
monsieur kramer qu avez-vous l'intention
de prendre cette fois ci un autre verre
de champagne
monsieur kramer puis je me permettre de
vous donner un conseil profitez de votre
séjour pour admirer les merveilles de
notre pays ne nous fait pas travailler
trop nous sommes déjà débordés je ne
vois pas ce que vous voulez dire
disons que vous êtes ici en vacances et
que ce sont de vraies vacances
laissez-vous vivre et ne penser à rien
surtout ne faites rien
c'est exactement les intentions comme il
sait le champagne jolies femmes à cette
fois vous danser merci
[Musique]
double
mais
vous avez les mémoires il faut l'excuser
mois solide
pour ne vous me dire à quoi je pensais
en vous regardant tout à l'heure quand
vous dansiez j'en ai une petite idée
il vous plaît le collier que portera
salins celui qu'elle porte ce soir le
beau celui ci est faux le véritable et
dans mon coffre fort il est d'ailleurs
il est à moi
plairait de le porter salez
une fois de temps en temps et toutes les
nuits dans quatre lits
préféré continuer à taper à la machine
je m'ennuie quand je ne travaille pas
[Musique]
moi
doux
m
tha
koné
au minck lui
mais qu'est ce que tu as encore tant que
china je t'aime mais toi tu finiras par
me décourager j'ai envie de coucher que
toutes les filles qui passent même la
secrétaire
sous prétexte qu'elle remue bien
l'espèce mais aussi chez le faire tiens
regarde
[Musique]
cette plaie ça
et
à
ouais
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
vous permet d quel culot il a tout même
ce type
qu'est-ce qu'il a pris tout à coup bas
votre façon de danser à de lui faire
l'effet d'une révélation qu'est ce
qu'elle a ma façon de penser a de quoi
contrarier la vocation d'un séminariste
[Musique]
n'empêche que c'est vraiment un sale
type
je trouverais bien quelque chose pour
l'embêter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
excusez moi un mot à dire à quelqu'un je
les imprime je reviens dans un assaut
[Musique]
sally champagne je voudrais donner un
ami les coordonnées de fulham sommes
allés le chercher mon agenda dans le
bureau maintenant oui oui il devrait
s'en aller
allez-y tout de suite vous en avez juste
pour un instant
[Musique]
mais l'autre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça vous fuyez j'ai été prendre tenait
seul mais whissell
et si quelqu'un a profité pour voler les
petites cuillères
je n'ai pas d'alibi monsieur bertini
monsieur bertili monsieur bertini
qu'est-ce que vous avez les thériault en
fait je veux dire monsieur conti il est
d'un bureau là par terre mais que
faisiez-vous dans mon bureau
j'étais venu chercher dès 6 heures vous
auriez pu me le demander il me l'a
demandé mais je n'ai pas trouvé utile de
déranger pour ça vous m'avez fait
appeler oui on a ouvert le coffre fort
et volé le collier qui se trouvaient à
l'intérieur
maintenant ici oui et monsieur contient
surpris deux cambrioleurs et celui ci
l'a sommée avec un vase
comment était-il ce voleur on sait rien
il m'attaque et pas derrière monsieur
kramer ou est ce que vous étiez pendant
cette dernière demi heure avec moi
depuis le départ de salies nous ne nous
sommes pas quittés
je vous pourriez le juré oui je pourrais
mais enfin ça lit vous n'avez vu
personnes qui s'enfuyaient
non je les trouvais comme ça monsieur
bertini à trouver votre absence un peu
longue
logiquement vous auriez dû apercevoir
monsieur conti tout de suite en entrant
je suis allée dans le bureau pour
prendre un agenda
il m'a fallu un certain temps pour le
trouver et en sortant là je me suis
retourné et j'ai vu enfin vous ne
supposez pas commissaire que cette
pauvre enfant puisse ouvrir un coffre
comme celui ci pourtant ce qu'offre
quelqu'un l'a ouvert c'est indéniable
les faits sont là
je ne sais comment vous l'avez fait
quand vous l'avez fait ni où vous avez
caché ce collier mais vous l'avez fait
admirable déduction de toutes façons le
voleur a perdu son temps et gâcher son
talent la présence de notre ami ici
présentant quelques risques
excusez moi mon cher kramer mais on ne
prête vraiment qu'aux riches j'ai pris
quelques précautions
du porte le vrai colis et ma chérie
c'est la copie qui a été dérobé dans le
coffre fort qu alors tout est bien qui
finit bien
sauf pour le voleur bien entendu mais
mais vous n'êtes absolument sûr de ne
pas vous tromper absolument un
commissaire il est donc inutile de
donner suite à ce petit incident donnent
mal collier ma chérie je remette à sa
place dans le coffre fort
ça m'étonnerait que le voleur face une
autre tentative ce soir on ne sait
jamais il ya peut-être parmi nous un
habile l'illusionniste venez vittorio
venez je vais vous faire un pansement
je vais rester dans cette pièce en
attendant qu'un de mes hommes viennent
me relever pour la nuit et nous allons
surveiller la maison jusqu'au départ de
tous vos invités et surtout de sam
kramer sait-on sacré kramer il m'a suivi
ma smith est servi il sait que c'est moi
qui ai ouvert le coffre ça m'étonnerait
qu'il en parle à qui que ce soit lui
seul est au courant de la substitution
qu'on a faite bertini et les autres sont
persuadé que le voleur s'est emparé du
faux collier chérie tu veux encore
partir avec moi pour l'australie puis
que jamais collier calme toi je savais
où je pouvais le négocier mais
maintenant calme toi il est bien trop
malin pour filer tout de suite et c'est
une chance qu'il était épaulé par lui du
drot avec ça montrera sûrement le moyen
de récupérer
et si c'était pour lui mais qui veux-tu
que ce soit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
police
vous désirez
si je veux si jérémy ab noir excusez moi
il n'ya vraiment pas de quoi
cannes au contraire oui c'est tellement
transparence et machel
on ne s'en plaint pas vous permettez que
je prenne un bonbon quand je n'arrive
pas à m'endormir je suis toujours un bon
jour bien sûr et si vous n'avez pas
sommeil
on peut prendre un verre on peux
bavarder un peu non merci j'ai pas soif
et puis quel qu'il peut entrer et me
trouver avec vous dans cette tenue oui
mais maintenant tout le monde dort on ne
sait jamais vous savez je n'ai pas le
droit de dormir
et maintenant que je vous ai vu j'aurais
du mal aux frais mois au moins bon bon
ils surent très sucré et forcément ce
sont des bonbons j'adore les sucreries
son point est-ce qu'il y en à la
framboise no hay
[Musique]
excusez moi et y en a plus ils sont tous
pareils voilà enfin monsieur au revoir
c'est joli à regarder mais ça une
cervelle d'oiseau
alors comme ça on se lève la nuit pour
manger des bonbons donné mandat au moins
vous aussi aux non laissez moi même
couché ne voudrais pas entrer
si si mais on n'entre pas dans la
chambre d'une femme à moitié nue en
pleine nuit pas pourquoi c'est le
meilleur moment
vous ne croyez tout de même pas que je
vais vous accueillir dans mon lit sous
prétexte que vous avez retaper le
courrier à ma place
[Musique]
il est urgent que nous ayons une petite
conversation tous les deux jeudis vous
embrasser rien de plus sain après je
vais admirer
[Musique]
vous n'auriez pas dû faire ça ça ne vous
plaît pas
[Musique]
c'est ça que je n'aime pas qu'est ce qui
vous est passé par la tête
vous le saviez j'ai des yeux les
oreilles partout alors je ne sais pas
j'ai pas réfléchi j'ai fait ça comme ça
mais laissez moi tranquille mon petit
tout ça risque de vous causer pas mal
d'ennuis
vous n'allez pas leur dire sam vous
n'allez pas me dénoncer ce serait mon
devoir de bon citoyen mais moi aussi
j'étais mon devoir
d'un point de vue j'ai vu un veau large
de la somme est oui seulement lorsque
vous avez trouvé le collier vous vous
êtes dit il mûrit aussi bien carrousel
un nom sam
si je voulais je leur à la place de
sanaa bertini me l'a proposé mais je le
déteste pertini c'est pour ça que j'ai
pris mon collier rinne pour l'embêter
et du même coup vous vouliez une santé
vittorio je comprends ce joli garçon
vittorio ciment matériau tout ce que je
voulais c'était voir la tête le ferais
bertini quand il ne trouvera plus son
fameux collier sa meule n'allais pas me
dénoncer
[Musique]
ne sais pas encore
c'est très vilain ce que vous avez fait
ça mais bon ça vous vous rendez compte
des risques que vous avez pris en allant
chercher cette bonbonnière sous le nez
d'un flic ça si on l'avait retrouvé avec
mes empreintes d'essence aveu savent
mener tout droit en prison vous en
preniez pour dix ou quinze ans ça
m'aurait beaucoup chagrine r
merci alors aussi il vaut mieux que je
parte
[Musique]
était un ancien ça je ne dois pas que
vous ayez des ennuis à cause de moi
vraiment je ne voudrais pas
[Musique]
et cette fin c'était pas seulement pour
vous remercie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en
[Musique]
un code qui vaut mieux qu'un long
discours
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dommage que tu te sois donné tant de mal
pour voler un faux collier
tiens je te le donne ça te fera un
souvenir
tu m'embrasses j'aime les hommes
d'action moi aujourd'hui et demain un
champion automobile
mais pourquoi ne pas faire un petit
essai tous les deux tu n'aimerais pas
tiens garde le médecin sur tille peut
toujours servir
[Musique]
oui
c'est quand même autre chose que les
ruines du michigan a c'est évidemment
assez différent du centre beaubourg pour
remplir tous a dit don ça marche était
atteint stand pas forcément les
spectacles de gladiator avait déjà
beaucoup de succès il me faudrait deux
personnes là pour garnir le cadre voilà
rené selliez allons-y très réussi ton
numéro d'hier soir bravo bercy
maintenant que nous avons apprécié et on
exploite une rome ont connu lequel le
fonds tient à la prince non mais celui
qui a été volé c'est le fou est alors
que comptes-tu enfer demain je le
garderai un souvenir
si seulement je l'avais tu as tout
compris maintenant ne jouons pas aux
plus fins au collier je le veux j'ai
très bien compris en effet tu ne veux
pas me rendre mais demandent le plus tôt
à celui qui a sommé victorio ce n'est
pas moi tu es un complice dans la maison
où peut-être une complice envoyons aux
anneaux alors je suis un solitaire tout
de suite
ça c'est très bon très très bon travail
allez on y va oui
[Musique]
vous n'avez pas froid non moi j'arrive
pas moins chauffer mois ou avez vous mis
de côté ne vous inquiétez pas pour ça
quand je pense que victorieuse balade
avec nous comme si de rien n'était
vraiment il manque pas de culot solaire
n'y pensez plus il règne une vilaine
odeur surtout ça bien trop vilaine pour
un hors-jeu leptine et que le vôtre
faites moi confiance
les méchants seront punis cette petite
bourde il est évident qu'elle lui plaît
mais ne te dis qu'elle lui plaît une
femme voit ça tout de suite
je suis sûr qu'elle est dans le coup
avec lui
aller à des montres arthur vite aller
assis là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
je
oui
non
respect
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ado les mêmes riz vous êtes mal informé
je ne l'est pas il est dans le coffre de
monsieur bertini année nous le problème
sera mère et je vous préviens nous avons
un expert parmi nous
alors pas de blague ou la demoiselle va
nourrir les poissons passé là moi alors
j'ai autant confiance en vos quand un
sac de vipère passé là moi
juste quelques mots et pas de phrases à
double sens en ce compris aller au sam
oui ça va j'aimerais bien ne pas trop
rester ici parce que ils n'ont pas de
kleenex
qu'est ce que ça veut dire que j'ai
envie de me moucher le convaincu alors
fait vie d'accord d'accord et oui j'ai
très bien compris l'adresse pas de
police bien entendu mais vous faites
très attention la demoiselle ou alors
vous le regretterez de mauvaises
nouvelles
on a enlevé s'allient pour l'échanger
contre le collier pourquoi
s'adresse-t-on à moi je suis pour rien
dans tout ça j'ignore ce qui s'est passé
et puis je commence à en avoir assez de
cette histoire surtout c'est sallie qui
doit en faire les frais maintenant que
comptez-vous faire décider bertini à
faire les changes
il y va de la ville cette pauvre enfant
il menace de la tuer si on ne leur donne
pas le vrai colis mais c'est insensé
je n'accepterai jamais de leur donner si
bertini parce qu'on a essayé de vous
rouler et vous savez très bien qui oui
je sais rossana et vittorio vous les
filets avec le collier mais c'est vous
qui l'avez volet d' où l' enlèvement de
salies par un de leurs complices pour
m'obliger à le rendre
seulement voilà je ne l'est pas alors où
est il dans votre coffre
je suis désolé maintenant je peux vous
dire que hier soir j'ai menti
osan a porté pendant la réception le
faux collier c'est lui que j'ai mis dans
le coffre fort non bertini lorsque
victorio ats mais il avait déjà fait les
changes
ils sont persuadés que c'est moi qui est
le vrai collier mais en réalité il est
là et vous voulez que je leur donne pour
mieux le leur reprendre ensuite vous la
voler votre petite revanche oui ou non
d'accord ils vont l'avoir
mais cette [ __ ] va me le payer ne me
posez pas de questions et fait
exactement ce que je vais vous dire un
petit baiser d'abord et avant d'autres
choses sachez que je garderai de vous le
plus délicieux souvenirs tous partis oui
je ne reste jamais très longtemps au
même endroit
damages mais vous pouvez me rendra très
grands services
bien sûr sam quand vous me verrez partir
avec pertini arrangez vous pour vous
trouver seul avec vittorio faites-lui
votre grand numéro de charme
et puis retenez bien ce que je vais vous
dire
ils diront oui avec le collier que
frédéric hoarau mis dans le coffre
mais c'est le faux collier il ne croit
tout de même pas qu'il va nous avoir
aussi facilement non si ça m'avait tu le
vrai il n'aurait pas agi comme ça entre
la vie de la fille et un collier il
n'aurait pas pris un tel risque
alors il a dit la vérité il n'est pas
rare qu on s'est tous fait avoir
victorieux mais par qui bon dieu je ne
sais pas mais par quelqu'un qui a
profité des circonstances j'ai un
problème avec ma chaise longue vous ne
voudriez pas venir m'aider vittorio je
me désole margerie mais je suis occupé
je peux tu es le chiper une minute rien
ne presse maintenant victoria normal
j'ai à vous parler vittorio c'est pas le
moment margerie si je vous dis que c'est
moi qui vous ai cassé le vase sur la
tête m'accorderai bien cinq minutes ce
que vous racontez
je passais dans le couloir quand j'ai vu
une petite lumière près du coffre fort
j'ai tout de suite compris
je suis entré sans faire de bruit et
boum
seville hassan vittorio
je croyais que vous n'aviez pas quitter
kremer tout le monde le soupçonnait ce
pauvre garçon j'ai voulu l'aider j'ai un
faible pour les hommes qui vit
dangereusement alors pourquoi m'avoir
assommer un réflexe de femmes honnêtes
passionnel que ça
puisque vous avez gardé le collier mais
j'ai été bien déçu quand j'ai vu qu'ils
étaient faux j'arrive pas à croire que
vous avez fait ça non il vous faut une
preuve
[Musique]
mais évitez comment dire de faire une
grosse bêtise j'avais besoin de beaucoup
d'argent des dettes de jeu
je veux bien garder tout ça pour moi
mais il faudra être aussi gentil avec
moi qu'avec roanne évidemment je n'aurai
pas à me forcer
il faut se débarrasser de ça c'est bien
trop compromettants
faites dans ce que vous voulez mais
n'oubliez pas que si ça avait été
quelqu'un d'autre
vittorio j'aurais été moins discrète
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu fais en maillot c'était
prendre un bain pour calmer tout de
suite regarde c'est impossible
oula tu trouves de soutien s'étaient
margerie je t'explique la plus tard
aller vite on enregistrait temps
d'attraper l'avion
[Musique]
que de noms
rassurez vous nous sommes seuls nous
n'avons pas prévenu la police
saly saly savas ali oui ça va on est
tranquille selway
[Musique]
les bains le soir nom de dieu il faut
sortir d'ici tout de suite
bon alors écoutez je finissais de la
détacher je m'occupe de la porte mais
oui
dépêchons-nous s'est pas beaucoup de
chair cette histoire monsieur batignole
je suis désolé or assurez-vous il se
rattrapera merci décidément vous êtes un
drôle d'outil allait dépêcher vous
attendez moi je pourrais bien
commissaire
[Musique]
salut à tous
alors rien passé mois le commissaire or
signé à la haut commissaire a enseigné
ici bertini
[Musique]
la police charme l'aéroport où il va
vous êtes sûr qu'ils vont s'y retrouver
le seul sur une île où ne croyait pas
qu'après ça ils vont se laisser piéger
in fine on est en fait c'est quoi ce qui
se passe je comprends rien raddo ça
serait trop long
[Musique]
on va
qu'est ce qu'ils foutent ils ont raté
l'avion
[Musique]
il
le
[Musique]
non
oh
[Musique]
le dispositif est en place
vous êtes bien sûr de ne pas vous
tromper je n'arrive pas à y croire vous
le croirez quand vous l'aurez vu
surtout n'intervenez pas avant qu'ils
aient remis le collier
faux
[Applaudissements]
il était temps donné tirez vous ça lui
convient pour nous oui je vous dis que
vous avez une info à l'étirer paraît
proche comprends pas dit si allez vous
tirer aujourd'hui tirez vous allez-y
c'est moi
non
à
et
non mais de quoi je me mêle
et s'il avait sorti ce revolver ce sont
les risques du métier
mais justement c'est quoi au juste votre
métier les bermudes en cette saison
c'est féerique
il faut que vous voyez ça vous douté de
rien vous avez besoin oui mais
frederico je ne voulais pas c'est lui
qui m'a forcé embarqué
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
mais à tes souhaits sage arthur coucher
je me demande ce que va devenir bertini
aux oubliés ce vilain monsieur zone
affreux marchands de canons auriez vous
couvrir vous allez prendre soin à m
tenez mettez ça ça vous réchauffera le
coeur
[Musique]
c'est dommage qu'ils soient fous rires
ah non celui là c'est le vrai mais alors
vous êtes un esthète ma chérie la preuve
voulez-vous m'épouser quoi ah ça
sûrement pas pourquoi vous n'aimez pas
des chiens n'est ce pas arthur par tu tu
vas pas me sur ce coup là anonops tous
les matins deux bonds à les disculper du
caviar ça toi alors maintenant je peux
les poser
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
à
[Musique]
bon je vais acheter un journal et je
reviens
je te signale que l'on a déjà pardon je
te signale que tu en a déjà un
ah oui mais j'ai besoin de me faire une
idée générale sur la région et sur la
faune qui l'habitent
et oui oui et oui par la même occasion
ben regarde tu en as un très beau
spécimen là où ça en riant à tout à
l'heure
j'emmène le chien oui oui
tiens si tu as un problème appelle moi
et bien leur madame vous me le donner ce
journal je n'ai aucune raison mais ce
qui fait la beauté du geste pour un
journal vous permettez que je vous pose
quelques questions enfin je ne vous
connais pas vous est ici en vacances
oui je suis en vacances là dans le coin
par là avant lui qu'est ce que vous
faites
ben je me promène et vous qu'est ce que
vous faites ici le journal sérieux
détective privé je suis un détective
privé mais je peux vous dire que vous
venez de vous baigner moi et aussi que
vous êtes une danseuse au nom
[Musique]
nous rencontrer moi je vous trouve
absolument savoir si on va se baigner
faudrait peut-être y aller oui oui oui
ça c'est une idée oui c'était fin au non
non non non absolument pas quand il n'y
avait pas de monnaie alors j'ai payé sur
son dos noir commence par un journal à
dieu sait où ça peut mener
on n'en sortira jamais je vois plus
confiant non parce que dès que j'ai beau
tourner et tu recommences oies au fait
voir le ballet qui signe est ici qu ici
le chorégraphe avec lequel que eu des
mots ou en fin d'étape ou fait chier
mais laura était ma meilleure amie sam
il faut absolument que je représente
avec plaisir
[Musique]
il
m
hé hé
belle lycée beauregard ligne alors maire
de saint-quentin d'être à mon avis oui
mais il s'appelle arthur lui aussi ah
oui c'est mon nom et bien moi c'est le
nom de mon chien
arthur syrie est-ce que je peux
présenter ça mon mari condoléances laura
nepad a géré enfants est allé déjeuner
avec son pauvre petit papa et moi je
fais le poireau il est ici où il est
venu quelques jours pour voir danser sa
petite fille
et toi oh moi je voyage beaucoup avec
sam
tu sais que j'ai abandonné la danse qui
a très bien fait le croyez non ce jour
les dire si la danse est un métier
difficile qui demande beaucoup de
sacrifices
n'est ce pas ça lui l'ignorent monsieur
benson ils étaient masqués ils ont
laissé un message
mais non ne prévenait surtout pas la
police sinon votre film aura alors allez
à votre répétition normalement comme si
de rien n'était dit seulement qu'elle
s'est sentie un peu souffrante et
qu'elle a dû rester auprès de moi bien
je ferai comme vous dites monsieur
manson
tout à fait mal non ça va j'échoue smac
leurs excuses et le baiia deux types lui
sont tombés dessus et ont embarqué la
fille qui se trouvait avec lui du beau
boulot vite est bien fait quelle fille
alors à benson la vedette du ballet
comment sont ils ces deux types mais un
vrai dire moi je sais pas c'est vrai
j'ai pas la mémoire des détails
essayez de vous souvenir est ce que la
mémoire vous revient maintenant
l'un des deux a perdu ça j'ai pas pu
bien voir leur tête parce qu'ils avaient
des casques de pilates et la voiture un
buggy blanc et bleu le numéro le numéro
cette [ __ ] de mémoire oh mon dieu tu
peux être maladroit c'est incroyable ça
t'es ok tu fais qu'est ce qui t'arrive
et je suis tombé dans l'escalier et
laura elle est restée avec son père est
un peu souvent malade et un estropié
matthew modine mois poursuivi par les
mauvais génies mais j'arrête ou je vais
me pendre tendre une corde une porte on
assistera ne me retire pas joué
qui êtes vous monsieur ça me kramer
c'est à quel sujet mais tout n'est pas
perdu un couteau comme celui là par
hasard
pourquoi me posez vous une question
aussi stupide au simplement parce qu'à
force de les lancer à droite et à gauche
il se pourrait qu'il y en est un qui se
soit égaré entre les épaules de
quelqu'un
les miennes par exemple regarder tenez
regardez a soumis à dire fois
heureusement j'ai eu le réflexe de
bouger j'ai l'habitude maintenant je
sens
pas tout puisque dieu comme ça alors là
c'est sûr il est au bout et l'échappée
belle
je suis certes elle finira par me tuer
bon alors en arrêt technique quand je te
le dirai va m'attendre dans ma loge et
plus un mot compris pauvre minable
eh bien cher maître il ne me reste plus
qu'à vous servez n'oubliez pas ceci ce
qu'ils ont fait à ces hippies prouve
qu'il ne plaisante pas monsieur kramer
ne vous mêlez pas de cette affaire je
tiens trop à ma fille ils sont capables
de tout benson même d'encaisser la
rançon et qui sait assassiné laura je
vous en prie bill ayez confiance en
somme il ne s'engage jamais à la légère
mais ma petite sa liste ce n'est pas un
manque de confiance mais ce qui m'arrive
est tellement déconcertant que je me
méfie de tout dieu sait si ma vie a été
mouvementée où est elle rencontre erlaf
pour la première fois en france il l'a
fait engager dans les ballets kisling et
depuis ils ne se sont plus jamais
quittés
j'étais venu pour organiser une petite
fête à l'occasion de leurs fiançailles
ayez confiance benson je ne ferai rien
qui puisse mettre en danger la vie de
votre film mais il faut d'abord savoir à
qui nous avons affaire
il faut pour cela attendre un nouveau
contact
alors si oui formidable écoutez je ne
veux pas une partie de plaisir chéri est
excusé je vous lance ruiz sa spontanéité
contraire nous touche beaucoup
tenez moi au courant le plus vite
possible allez viens arabe il au revoir
merci
on
mais qu'est ce que je dis mal encore tu
es adorable ne réponds moi moi ça te
dirait de danser à nouveau je sais pas
oui pourquoi
pour m tournait dans ce théâtre tu vas
faire tes offre de services à kisling
pour remplacer laura ont il ya un an
j'ai pas compétence est là justement ça
te fera beaucoup de bien
[Musique]
fin du xviiie 18,3 à mon âge tu te rends
compte
c'est une folie je crois quand j'aurai
80 à 100 je vais encore quand même je
trouve que vous êtes en plein vol hoguet
retard garde le beau garçon à la voiture
blanche
tu le vois je connais tu me présente à
rien
[Musique]
et
bonjour mademoiselle est ce que je
pourrais parler au directeur s'il vous
plaît oui bien sûr je crois qu'il est au
fond là bas près du bar bien vont penser
que je peux le voir sans déranger bien
sûr je vous en prie merci vous êtes
charpy quel que soit votre handicap joué
avec lui en est insoutenable
où
[Musique]
je vous prie de m'excuser vous ne seriez
pas le directeur de ce club oui je
voudrais m'inscrire
c'est un club privé monsieur il faut
être parrainé rien de plus simple
monsieur est un ami dans ce cas je vous
laisse madame la comtesse carton de
winne a enchanté et doit le hasard me
surprendra toujours
mais il mon père est le président du
club
non dans ce cas là si vous avez la
patience d'attendre que je vais aller
chercher souvenez certainement à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
m
on
[Musique]
non écoute je fais un gros effort mais
on remplace pas l'aura comme ça au pied
levé quand tu l'as bien je m'en dire un
petit chien qui fait public autant
réverbère c'est vrai quoi tu tiens me
ridiculiser et on va du tout montré leur
écoute enfin c'est pas compliqué ce que
je demande regarde moi à regarder et les
greens été unanime a été pourrie
l'ancien en tonnes métriques
si vous pouvez
foster
[Musique]
à
hu
ouh ouh
voilà un papa je te présente sam kramer
les amis de ma fille sont les bienvenus
et comme je le lui refuse absolument
rien eh bien je suis ravi de vous
accueillir au club cher monsieur vous
connaissez guertin depuis longtemps
[Musique]
ah oui oui oui cette fête est très drôle
d'histoire
nous nous sommes connus depuis ça fait
bien trois mois
ah oui oui oui déjà
le temps passe n'est ce pas gil rojas hr
comice fait ça me kramer enchanté vous
faites un parcours comme ça oui pour me
détendre un peu votre nom monsieur me
dit quelque chose
et oui mon père était dans la police
vraiment jouer fait il restait six mois
il a très vite compris
1 dans ce cas votre nom me reviendra
certainement bien nous devrons partir
occupez vous de votre inscription au
revoir monsieur quand même au revoir
dans un parcours demain demain e voyant
demain demain demain demain oui pourquoi
pas il vient au revoir
[Musique]
mademoiselle une limonade avec deux
glaçons qui brille à qui distribuez bout
c'est joli petit 2 à lui même sans toute
nouvelle on les a depuis hier
j'ordonne novembre du club et aussi au
personnel fait-il que vous en ayez une
je ne vous ai encore jamais réussi je
vous promets que je vais revenir très
souvent des toits lorsque vous ne cachez
pas la moitié de votre anatomie derrière
ce bar que faites vous
[Musique]
salut les filles salut salut a tous
voila quoi eh ben tu vois tout arrive
bon accueil est cette médaille vient de
la trouver c'est à moi vous l'aï trouvé
dans ta le jeu par terre merci alors
c'est fini pour de petites affaires
personnelles oui on peut travailler un
peu si ça continue comme ça on court à
la catastrophe
[Musique]
j'ai envie de sortir messieurs nous
travaillons moi aussi police je dois
procéder à l'interrogatoire de toute la
troupe vous viendrez dans le bureau du
directeur l'une après l'autre
quelle est la danseuse qui remplace le
robinson moi je commençais par vaux et
la voilà repartie ce vieux fou écoute
mons où tu fais tes valises une fois
pour toute c'est plus possible
et puis moi je devais partir en vacances
je sens le bénévolat c'est le spectacle
et foutez vous semblez oublier monsieur
qu il s'est commis un crime dans ce
théâtre et dans deux minutes il va y
avoir un suicide monsieur le commissaire
et jeudi devant les témoins suicide toi
vous serez responsable à vos places
prises alors vous travaillez dans le
ballet depuis qu'on a enlevé leur à
benson oui vous connaissiez le rebelle
jeunes absolument pas fait comme si elle
était la manche où tu veux position'
please bon moment bonjour j'ai fait il
ne vous dérangez pas pour moi je ne fais
que passer sa vie n'est pas là à
direction avec le commissaire va y avoir
un second crime
ah ça va y avoir un second crime and
roll il va y avoir un second qui est sûr
c'est évidemment de ne vous énervez pas
de musique mais je n'ai jamais vu le
robinson et même le jour où vous êtes
arrivé ici puisque je vous dis jamais
s'est jamais jamais jamais que vous a
permis d'entrer ici je vous présente ma
femme et comme nous ne faisons jamais
rien sans l'autre je ne la quitte jamais
même dans les moments pénibles entrée de
votre femme dans le ballet quand un site
curieusement avec le jour où l'on
assassiné ce hippie ce qui veut dire ce
nom simple rapprochement des faits qui
pourrait peut-être nous amener à une
piste vous avez parfois de curieux
raisonnement
ce qui veut dire que ça ne veut rien
dire du tout savez-vous contre arrogance
monsieur kramer pourrait bien vous jouer
des tours c'est drôle mais votre nom me
dit quelque chose
cherchez bien commissaire et quand vous
aurez trouvé prévenu naturellement vous
restez à notre disposition vient
d'organiser sa vie il va rejoindre
kisling minutes en état de dépression
enfin
où vas tu comme quoi je vais faire un
petit footing avec qui je te trouve bien
dans les corps pour faire du footing
[Musique]
tête fatigue pas trop quand même
oh
[Musique]
histoire tu
et
c'est ça le footing
[Applaudissements]
non
monsieur crown et je peux vous parler un
moment et attendez moi alors pas trop
fatiguant d'un footing
non mes copains ne sois pas stupide
c'est la fille du patron
je suis sûr que tout pas dit si elle est
très douce et agréable dans les coûteux
c est dire l'entente jeudi
il fait la compétition c'est là-bas que
tu me met très utile tu sais que tu
toujours un peu inquiète mais oui mais
non non ne ne t'inquiète pas la balle
jaune courent aucun risque
une folle qui me suit partout
elle est folle de moi vous savez ce que
c'est quand on plaît chez la plaie
[Musique]
en
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
via mon bébé moi tu fidal toi car tu
arthur arthur
or tu reviens ici arthur arthur arthur
souhaitait revenir ici arthur or tu
viens ici bien sûr tu reviens me tue va
de toute façon tu es quoi c'était dans
un cul-de-sac
qu'est ce que vous faites ici j'étais au
bar et et mon chien s'est échappé je ne
cherchais voit la table un petit fugard
mais c'est vrai pen ne serait comme ça
je peux marcher tout seul vous avez été
invité par qui personne je venais tout
seul c'est un club privé ici
mademoiselle allez suivez moi un méandre
et on a surpris jeune fille dans le
couloir et alors elle fait partie du
club maintenant laissez-nous il est joli
je vous en prie venez vous asseoir voilà
ça y est vous là
je suis désolé d'avoir enfreint les
règles de votre établissement j'avais
simplement envie de prendre un verre
l'endroit me parut plaisant russie s'est
échappée voilà est venu accuser le zèle
de paix assistant mais les membres ne
tolère aucune dérogation même pour une
jolie femme alors vous êtes directeur
son fils mademoiselle et son bras droit
il est absent jusqu'à demain ce soir ils
organisent une fête dans sa villa
ce soir et vous avez sont très ennuyeuse
j'ai décidé de ne pas y aller si vous le
permettez nous pourrions partager un
dîner au champagne dans l'appartement
si ça ne vous semble pas trop pas
convenant je suis sûr que l'été indien
tenu alors je vous attends à 9 heures
si les membres du club y trouve rien à
dire oublions cela on va vous
raccompagner louis accompagné
mademoiselle
[Musique]
moi je veux bien mais je trouve que tu
as fait un peu drôle un bon écoute tout
ce qu'il faut plus il sera excité et
puis ça sera temps pour agir bon alors
fais ce que tu veux fait de même
attention j'ai l'impression que ce ne
sont pas des enfants de choeur
d'ailleurs enfin en choeur ou pas tu
ferais damner un saint qui pam un final
au finalement à aller en piste
arthur vient faire dans le monsieur
ravissement
ça ne vous ennuie pas de charme d'arthur
avec moi non au contraire c'est grâce à
lui que vous êtes ici je criais vous ne
venez pas vous êtes éblouissante
louis
[Musique]
faisant prévu au dessus
j'ai fait préparer un petit souper nous
passerons à table quand vous voudrez
rien ne presse
la nuit nous appartient
ti
détendez vous
c'est chaud pour un peu gérer plonger
dans la piscine pourquoi pas c'est une
manière aucune importance nous sommes
seuls justement qu'allez vous pensez ce
que vous imaginez alors vous n'avez pas
confiance aussi au pouce et j'ai
entièrement confiance en vous un peu de
champagne louis cervélo s'il vous plaît
eh bien monsieur
[Musique]
laura elle est sur un bateau lui et
surtout pour taro ça
[Musique]
on ne bouge plus on écoute ce que je dis
et on exécute de sans perdre de temps
téléphoner heinrich dit à lui de
descendre immédiatement
[Musique]
allo
qu'est ce que vous racontez
[Musique]
oui attendez moi j'arrive veuillez
m'excuser je reviens tout de suite
on ne bouge toujours pas on ne bouge pas
merci
ouais
grammaire et sa femme sont vraiment trop
curieux il faut hâter les choses et en
finir avec eux bien monsieur rotman
c'est son problème et je sais mais elles
vidées pour moi c'est l'essentiel
les ravisseurs doivent me rappeler à
midi pour me donner leurs instructions
oubliez ce que je vous ai dit sam
je préfère les payer et être sûr de
revoir ma fille vivante vous compreniez
d'accord il faut payer en effet ou du
moins leur les et loire mais si vous
voulez retrouver l'aura vivante
laissez-moi agir c'est non je n'ai pas
l'âme d'un juste et si je me fout qu'il
soit puni ou non c'est une organisation
extrêmement dangereuse
il faut qu'elle soit détruite et je
tiens surtout à rendre leurs en bonne
santé
merci
on
version de finalement le dépasser
ce n'est pas très facile mais laissez
moi un peu de temps pour agir
je sais que vous êtes pressés mais
essayer de comprendre c'est une affaire
délicate pour moi
si je fais la moindre erreur tout peut
être découvert je vous promets de faire
tout mon possible pour réussir très bien
monsieur rotman
[Musique]
vous
com
[Musique]
que lui
plus activement encore dit au couple de
vos amis de ne plus se mêler de cette
affaire
c'est une condition vous avez entendu
sam c'est sans appel je vous le demande
en amis ne vous en mêlez plus alors
permettez nous de rester avec vous je
suis aussi très inquiète pour nora vous
êtes très gentille somme vous comprenez
bien entendu ne craignez rien je serai
discret je vous le promets merci vous
les prenez tous les deux oui mais qu'est
ce que tu veux faire des sacs de couleur
en garder un bon souvenir
[Musique]
m
tout est en ordre
oui je vous laisse donc agir seul
absolument je suis sûr que tout ira bien
ainsi
voulez vous mettre ceci je voudrais
également que vous téléphoniez un de mes
amis monsieur olaf martensson main voici
le numéro détruit que monsieur batman
lui ordonne de venir immédiatement au
club est alors avec fermeté à bout dit
ça sans vous domaine non c'est une
plaisanterie que nous faisons entre amis
et je sais ça fait alors qu'on lui
réserve une petite surprise
il doit en être morte de peur bien sûr
je suis un fana des canulars moi aussi
est ce que vous êtes gentil tenez mais
aussi que c'est comme si c'était fait
[Musique]
et alors pourquoi tu t'es déjà billet je
sorte un moment excuse moi mais où tu as
vu jouer ça tu ne sors pas tu vas
répéter avec les autres autrement tu
peux dire adieu à ta place de premier
danseur je sais mais ce que j'ai à faire
est trop important mais qu'est ce qui
est plus importante que la danse tu
jetterait comme ça ta carrière aux
orties c'est désormais fait attention ne
pousse pas à vous parce que je vais
piquer une grosse colère je sens tu
restes ici où je des 30 devant tout le
monde mais proprement répéter les
enchaînements sans moi je ne serai pas
long
d'accord mais souviens toi que le grand
diaghilev a même chassé nijinski musique
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
au jour là
alors comment va la santé laissez moi
passer je suis pressé c'est moi qui vous
ai téléphoné à la part othman qui est
rotman hall a rassemblé de vous souvenir
vous êtes membres de son organisation
politique
les caisses du parti sont alimentés par
des enlèvements spectaculaires tels que
celui de laura benson dont vous êtes
responsable je ne comprends pas ce que
vous dites kramer et votre médaille à
côté de la malle du lanceur de couteaux
et l'assassinât de juifs
je pourrais ajouter que l'enlèvement de
votre fiancée ne vous a pas beaucoup
perturber non nous aurions dû en finir
avec vous depuis longtemps mais il n'est
pas encore trop tard
ça y est comme ça y est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
rain man est un livre pratique encore
entre nos mains humaines ne l'oublié pas
alors y règne et les bords mais l'homme
[Musique]
on
à
[Musique]
allez mange
qu'est ce que vous voulez on a envoyé
chercher la fille j'ai pas reçu d'ordre
du patron fais ce que je te dis vite
bon d'accord comme vous voulez monsieur
la salis aulas olaf
mais qu'est ce que vous faites ici
attention
[Musique]
m
oh
[Musique]
vous avez commis une faute très grave il
est trop tard pour vous justifiez vous
avez voulu jouer au plus malin benson
cela va vous coûter très cher vous
comprenez ce que je veux dire
mais écoutez moi je n'y suis pour rien
je ne comprends pas quelqu'un à changer
les billets à mon insu nous avons été
posséder tous les deux je vous supplie
de me croire ma décision est prise
[Musique]
et
c'est votre voiture oui
[Musique]
vous comprendrez que dans une affaire de
kidnapping ne faut jamais céder au
chantage mais je n'ai pas cédé au
chantage commissaire je les fais
qu'exécuter les ordres
mettez vous à ma place mais c'est
précisément notre rôle monsieur benson
mais cela semble vous avoir échappé vous
auriez mieux fait de nous appeler au
mieux de faire confiance à cet
aventurier d'opérette regarde c'est
grâce à messali tu te rends compte de ce
qu'ils nous convoquent possible c'est
meirieu sam et vous salies comment
pourrais-je vous remercier
si vous saviez ce que laura représente
pour moi enfin ce serait trop loin vous
expliquez nous vous devons la vie je
n'ai rien de plus précieux au monde
commissaire vous voyez nous avons eu
tort tous les deux pour ce qui est de
votre fille admettons que vous ayez
raison mais les ravisseurs sont toujours
en liberté et l'argent de la rançon n'a
pas été récupéré et c'est votre argent
voilà toute ma fortune commissaire je
vous laisse tout le bénéfice de
l'opération commissaire et je peux
récupérer la rançon
mais pour cela n'intervient pas 24
heures comment la police n'a pas été
prévenu vous faites votre petite salade
tranquillement dans votre coin et en
plus vous venez me donner des ordres
mais dites moi vous comprenez pourquoi
la police monsieur travers et je voulais
déjà dire un votre nombre revient cinq
rats mais c'est ça oui la sphère du
collier de syracuse et l'autre le faux
rembrandt vous avait refilé à la mafia
bravo joli tableau de chasse
écoutez ne le dit pas comme il sait
reconnaître de votre intelligence
attache de l'importance de tels travaux
enfin quatre années tout quatre
commissaires vous ne pouvez pas lui
refuser après ce qu'il vient de faire
pour moi toute cette histoire n'est pas
très clair parfait je m'incline
[Musique]
ciao
l'eau
les deux relais et pas de temps à perdre
mesure au vannes oc veut dire quoi
l'obligeance de bien vouloir me remettre
le contenu de votre coffre vous me
prenez pour un enfant kramer vous
oubliez que la vie de laura benson est
entre mes mains non entretiennent ainsi
que la montre je vais vous en donner la
preuve approché seule europe 1
les autres face au mur
[Musique]
vous faut-il plus de précisions j'ai
obtenu du commissaire qu'un seul aux 24
heures de délai qui vous permettront de
disparaître donnant donnant vous me
perds et sa kramer pour le moment c'est
vous qui avez de la mémoire aller vite
[Musique]
merci ouais
n'oubliez pas 24 heures au revoir à
à propos pour votre yacht ne vous
inquiétez pas je me le cul
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
salut vous avez du feu
[Musique]
ah et il va bientôt falloir changer ses
pochettes il vous déplaisent non non
mais la maison pas changé de
propriétaire mais c'est encore un secret
o o
ciao ciao
[Musique]
24 heures je lui ai donné 24 heures non
vous devez lui faire confiance
commissaire sam est un homme de parole
sinon je ne serais pas là aujourd'hui
et vous oubliez qu'il vous offre cette
affaire sur un plateau oui oui mais je
connais bien à ce genre d'oiseau à cette
heure ci il s'est peut-être envolé avec
votre argent puisque benson sans moi ça
m'étonnerait de temps des vous comme il
sait il va venir voilà benson nouveau 2
millions de dollars pas un de plus pas
moi que ça vous est exceptionnel
commissaire show the promise chose due
si vous descendez dans les sous sols du
col balmoral
vous trouverez au fond du couloir une
corde d'antilopes alors tiré la
mobylette et la cheville est chère à
derrière vous trouverez la plus belle
brochette de grands méchants loups dont
rotman et chez rodman soi-même faux
dévots vers un paquet cadeau mais pas
besoin de vos services monsieur kramer
est à mon goût vous mêlez un peu trop d
affaires de la police
quand j'avais juste quelques petits
comptes à régler voilà qui est fait il y
a quelque chose qui n'est pas clair dans
cette affaire
si vous me permettez un conseil métier
où monsieur kramer
vous avez bien dit au sous sol oui oui
l'escalier quête à droite du bar vous
descendez c'est au fond du couloir
vous verrez il y à deux cornes
d'antilopes il suffit de choisir la
bonne tombe bien c'est tu savais 500 et
ce n'est pas tout alors on fait la fête
larhant bill samedi emmène faire la fête
non vous êtes mais habité tout étudiant
vous venez chez moi d'accord bien
allons-y au papa
pauvre robben alors ce sujet dit pour
votre yacht
ne vous inquiétez pas je m'en occupe
[Rires]
alors finalement l'état qui se battent
au met à new machine et non mais si bien
su ça crie ça ben alors là
chapeau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
[Musique]
et
oh
ouais
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
à
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh